it's seen oh my god this is the top
three coolest action moments of all time
what is the movie all of the background
you're seeing is not real oh hi mark hey
what's up welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artist react
we got Sam on the couch today instead of
Clint rip Clint but you know I got the
funnies and I got those natty reactions
I have no idea what we're gonna be
taking a look at today except for one
thing that I'm super excited about which
is the Mandalorians yes more on that
later
yes we're starting with the good weight
okay this is this that's fully CG yes a
SOI CG have you seen this movie I don't
know what we're looking I love this
movie movie it is a feast for the eyes
what is the movie Gaunt's zero yonce is
basically just one long fight scene with
different monsters so if you're looking
for something more than that you're
gonna be disappointed if you're looking
for one long cool fight scene with
monsters it's all in awesome CG you're
having a great time it's like this movie
basically takes all the coolest guns
smartin lasers Akira lasers mostly
lasers from pop culture and combines it
in the really cool monster fight
scenarios dude you just went to town
wait hold up Jesus this dudes
multiplying in the air this guy getting
shot and then regrowing is such a cool
effect and it's not that easy to do with
complicated models like this a boolean
is when you have one object and you
subtract another object from it so I
mean this guy gets chopped by swords
they're basically luli aiming you know
the different parts of him and then like
changing those boolean's to regrow stuff
it's like a 3d printer yeah it actually
is like a 3d printer
[Music]
this scene oh my god this is top three
coolest action moments in all time but
the creativity in the weaponry and this
oh my god it is so insane
just wait was it gonna slice through
them like a lightsaber better than that
better upload what does that mean upload
where to outer space
it's a teleportation gun that teleports
chunks of the monster away from the
monsters body brain imagine if in Star
Trek when they teleported people they're
like hey just teleport his brain that's
how okay so cool like I love that they
have to like oh it was like a texture
map that's basically just like a cat
scanned like brain yeah and that's like
just probably an animated texture map
that's playing on like a plane as they
like you know moving away for sure wait
so that's more of like a reverse 3d
printing gun yeah somewhere in space
somebody is eating a very good sandwich
with some very fine deli meats check
this transition so he's teleporting
right one slice at a time it's
first-person view what happens when your
eyes get teleported whoa cool he's
seeing it go in the moment it hits his
eyes we actually see it cut across the
frame and that sort of wipe transition
is there some sort of like quantum
pairing stuff going on here I was able
to think when his brains in another
location oh yeah this whole movie
basically just one giant like real for
the effects company that did it yes okay
don't show any more I gotta watch this
tonight it's not true it's [ __ ] did
not hit her oh hi mark oh wow classic
she's probably wondering why are we
reacting to this where are the visual
effects well I can't tell where are they
they're on a green screen
this entire rooftop is a green screen
here's a thing for how bad but yet good
that the room is this green screen is
really well done I mean the first time I
watched clips of these scenes I was at
something's up with it but I instantly
forgot about it and stopped it like
analyzing it like it was good enough to
where I was just like oh maybe the
Lighting's just a little weird
the cameras we're but I wasn't like all
green-screen even compared to Hollywood
movies this is pretty solid green
screening did the perfect mirror
symmetry of that building behind them
they're kind of like rotated their
360-degree image just a little oh my god
you're right for me the thing that
breaks down the most on this is just the
lighting and the edge feather on the
actual brick especially that shot where
he's coming out of the doorway there by
the way like yeah where does that door
lead where does that door lead this is
the boss what they're doing is it looks
like a giant panorama that's just at a
very far away distance so there's no
parallax from like that house just
behind the building and like the
buildings off in the distance it's just
an image but it is tracked in 3d space
just all at the same distance behind the
wall it's weird but like it's directed
in a way like so it's such a clear
vision it's a good indication like if
you have really clear director vision
you're gonna make something unique these
sets are insane where do you think they
found this warehouse room to film in
well judging by the previous Star Wars
movies they probably made a giant
green-screen stage and then filmed
everything with the actors having no
idea where they were or what a context
of what they were doing but this is a TV
show they don't have time to do all the
effects for a place relax every single
shot I don't have time for that okay
what we're getting at is in this scene
all of the background you're seeing is
not real it is a real-time rendered
image on a LED screen it is not a
green-screen and it is not a real set
either there's parts of the set that are
real pretty much everything the
foreground that the actors are
interacting with is real but you know if
you just go ten feet beyond that
suddenly it becomes a fake set people
have done this in the past before but
the thing that makes this revolutionary
is that they're able to utilize it with
a moving camera mm-hmm the camera they
are filming with is 3d tracked and the
screen is constantly adjusting the
perspective of the background to match
the cameras perspective and that's crazy
and the only way you can do that is by
using a real-time game engine this is
not done after the fact this is done the
frame by frame so everything the camera
is capturing goes through the lens and
that's why it looks so natural the
greatest thing about this is that it
gives control back to the
photographers to actually line up their
shot it's a very seamless very
streamlined process and it allowed this
whole production to get all these crazy
locations on a very small budget yeah
it's crazy how you can do interior and
exterior scenes with it at all times
there's a guy with unreal loaded up on a
workstation and if they are trying to
get a certain shot they literally can
just move all the assets on screen right
there before they shoot it so you can
always get a bike flawless composition
so we were actually fortunate enough to
experience this technology in person
unreal invited us out to one of their
demonstrations with one of their light
stages now on the stage they actually
had a scene set up you can see really
clearly how the ambient light of this
real-time environment is being rendered
in unreal is actually affecting the
lighting on us in the foreground and the
edges look good because there's no like
king that needs to be pulled like our
hair actually looks correct the light
blooms correctly around us and most
importantly when you're there acting you
can just look around and see the
environment you don't have to pretend
you can just see it what's really cool
about the stage is it also solves a lot
of the common issues you face when
filming on a green screen such as very
reflective and glass transparent objects
that you can still properly see through
trying to pull a key on some of this
stuff is basically impossible and this
fixes all that it's so inspiring that
literally right now I'm working on a
mini version of this that we'll be able
to have in our own studio it won't have
the LED walls but it's gonna have the
capability to 3d track a camera and as
we're filming in in real time we are
making a video about all of that and if
you want to see it subscribe this is a
creature and they can't afford to have
you know eight episodes of a CG creature
like this in every scene so they have an
amazing actual physical puppet but shots
like this where he's walking down the
ramp
that's a CG baby Yoda and what's
interesting is that they actually
fine-tuned and revised the animation of
the CG baby Yoda to be kind of puppet
like so make it seem like the real
puppet the entire time that's a really
common issue you face and visual effects
is very often in reality it's not we've
been trained to see in movies no squibs
yeah when people get shot movies that's
not what real bullet hits look like
there's re
and then there's Hollywood reality and
everyone thinks that Hollywood reality
is what things actually look like so if
you make it look like real they think it
looks fake certain points you're like
obviously that's not a living creature
even with the most flawless rendering
and a movement and animation are you
you're never going to convince someone
that it's real but if you can convince
them it's a puppet
well puppets are real so now it's really
exactly like pretty much anytime you see
like baby Yoda actually walking it's a
CG baby yoga so they're currently
filming season two of the mandalorian
right now and there's so much that they
learned on making this one that they're
basically designing sets around this
concept and I love that idea so much huh
I can't wait for season two and how
they're just gonna kill it with their
sets we're gonna watch which shirt all
right Richard I like this shows fun one
the man I haven't actually seen that
which are Netflix just yet so I'm
getting a little preview
Wow wait I don't know hold up there what
a huge cast wait you got the wrong again
you got the wrong show Christian
Wow you were saying we should watch the
dragon part Ren and mature oh yeah it is
the casting is on Henry Cavill has made
a complete transformation in this
character what is this
Nick what is this The Witcher what like
this is the original Witcher okay so
it's a polish Witcher movie that came
out in 2001 it's the original Witcher I
don't know why you like the show so much
Ren it sucks knows that saint-cloud he's
a little too vaping sulfur they probably
just had no money to throw a visual
effects let alone anything like should
we do the dragon we there's no way we
can do it well then they're like sure
they actually run in front of explosion
they came out of fire I assume that was
promising yeah it was comps it was
comped what's the coolest thing you can
imagine a dragon explodes three guys on
horses fly out of the flames you're like
yeah that makes sense
I was tricked anyways if you guys have a
TV show movie scene a good bed the
effect doesn't matter he's doing the
comical actually I have a special
request I want to do a reaction to game
cinematics so he guys have a game
cinematic that shows a really cool
effect
dude I've got like 30 video clips stored
in my brain ready to show you but yeah
leave comments to it that works I've
heard tales of your kind which
we're very used to seeing dragons and in
shows and movies and so these dragons
specifically the gold dragon suffers a
little bit
this shot stands out to me as being a
little rough and it's a TV show oh I get
it those CG dragon feet are touching
that wall and you can see like between
its toes the wall is still bright and
it's a little strange look look how dark
the dragon's feet are the Dragons feet
are dark because there's no light
hitting them especially since it's like
you have this huge dragon body almost
entirely occluding this hole from all
the light that to the whole girl should
be pretty dark in general underneath him
the lights coming from that one hole in
the cave that's basically acting as a
giant softbox yet the dragon's shadows
here are crisp on the wall it's a little
strange having crisp shadows from a
giant softbox of a hole no I think the
root cause of the shot here and what
makes it seem weird is the fact that
they're blending a live-action plate
that's in a challenging lighting
scenario with the CG dragon whereas I
feel like if you were to re-approach
this shot you'd probably be better to
make the entire environment 100% CG what
do you have a 3d model the dragon and
you're trying to have them go through a
live plate what you're doing is you're
guessing the three-dimensional geometry
of that space if you don't get it like
spot on it can start looking a little
bit weird where the scene feels flat or
flatter than it should be and that I
think we see that with the feet here I
feel like they blew their entire VFX
budget on the opening scene of the first
episode yeah
boom nice slice it's like chopping a
crab leg man it's great this was a great
like opening the show when I saw this I
was like oh man this is gonna be great
see that's dude and then his face there
I mean how like his whole body just kind
of like that's great though that's some
good VFX yeah that's like in the moment
in Gaunt's when his brain teleports way
he's like man you friggin pulled that
that humdinger on me by throwing the
original Witcher so I'll never forgive
me for that hey guys we have a special
message for you
yeah that's right bleep here is today
when this video comes out and we wanted
to do something super special so we went
back in time and we grabbed one of the
most demanded one of the coolest items
ever the anime self-driving car long
sleeve that's right and it's also gonna
be paired up with a one-time-only retro
dashboard magnet so you guys are on the
store this weekend and this weekend only
the anime self-driving car long sleeve
and the dashboard magnet is gonna be
available only then there's a bunch of
other stuff on the store
we got backpacks we got hats joggers
celery we were selling celery celery
seven inch carriage bolts that's it we
hope you guys head on over to corridor
digital dot store we've got the anime
self-driving car long sleeve back from
the vault as well as a bunch of other
really cool stuff you know there's got a
lot of guests on this show lately but I
gotta say it's pretty pretty comfy here
I could get used to this every Saturday
9:00 a.m. Pacific we got a new video
coming out clap your hands
[Applause]